they tweet okay so I guess I should
preface this by stating even though it's
pretty obvious that I've never played
any final fantasy game I mean when I say
that I'm actually lying it a little bit
because I played I remember I borrowed
it off a friend one time when I was like
really really tiny and I don't even
remember which Final Fantasy it was I
think I played it for about an hour or
two I remember nothing so um yeah I
basically have never paid it any final
fantasy before and I haven't heard about
persona 5 lore'l no hear of time hey
Alex how am i liking the music so far
it's cute I thought it was cute when I
when I boosted it up I was like wow it's
nice but all I know really is that the
farm base for this game is huge there
are many many many games which always
put me off playing as I thought that you
had to start from the beginning
but then I got told recently that now
they're all kind of their own entities
so you can play one of them without
necessarily having to play all the
others which makes it a lot less
intimidating for me it's like you know
Game of Thrones leave it on up never
watched it because this is too many and
I I just could never catch up and then
the last series happens and nobody was
happy with it so I was like well no
point now but this is different so I'm
excited to play the demo people have
been very very positive about this demo
so yeah let's play I had a question to
ask you though should I play classic or
normal I don't really know which one to
choose the player control character will
attack and defend automatically allowing
you to focus on executing or normal I'll
so this is like old-school when it was
turn base I guess I'll do normal or
should I do easy
should I make life easy for myself
should I go easy it says you know
I probably do normal shouldn't I Travis
says normal Oh apparently this stream is
going to dictate to Nikki whether or not
they should buy the game well no
pressure no pressure at all no pressure
at all here we go
I'm opening the tub so I can not miss so
you're not gonna watch Game of Thrones
ever some people didn't like the ending
you couldn't miss out
I mean maybe one day but I feel like I
don't have enough time for that to be
honest if anything I prefer to maybe
read the books but then again there's so
many perks for penny to read as well
anyway let's play the game first ever
so I don't know if I'm supposed to know
who these characters are if I had played
are the ones I don't know if they're
unique to this game don't know spray
pretty though
[Music]
I mean the flower was gonna die anyway
it's been plucked out of the ground
sorry I mean also wholesome
[Music]
[Music]
it's very industrial is that why she was
so protective over the flowers is there
not much nature here
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know what that says behind my
head
yeah
[Applause]
ooh
big dude
get down here
the MMA hair love it I got a big sword
today
no do I do
who goes there
euro
okay shizer my head so attacked yeah I
know how to attack hold to unleash an
attack capable of hitting multiple
enemies okay
oh there's a Punisher mode there's a
commands menu
what's Punisher mode lets punish me
you're coming with us
it's amazing don't think so no I'm doing
here operator mo what the [ __ ] am i
doing I'm sure what the game will tell
me
[Music]
gonna help
hands where I can see them
[Music]
have fun
wait so they're like bad guys what's
this Oh balls what my head the gauge
feels as time passes try attacking with
something cycle once a bar is well you
your character can perform special
actions charges can be used immediately
I'll save try attacking the enemies
feeler gauge okay
no I think that's square again okay cool
go ahead no no I'm trying to hope you
can expand I'm gonna I'm probably gonna
have to move my head to the other side
and screen this face and try using one
of the commands oh yeah I love this
spells fire this he could use magic I
like this school they've updated it so
now a lot of them chatting about this
game to some of my friends and they were
saying one of the reasons they didn't
like it because the turn-based combat so
now they don't have an excuse I check
them out
[Music]
okay I could look up for an icon wait
one second
this is gonna make my life so much
easier I'm just gonna move my face
because it's gang in the way
there you go I'm on the other side now
okay
drop the weapon
you got this yeah what he said
in defense pressing are ones because all
[Music]
okay you're coming with us it's crowded
come on try harder right come on guys
Jimmy no none of that
oh I see so cycles to judge
[Music]
let's do
[Music]
nothing doing
how do i lock onto them before and do a
spell on them I can't
[Music]
money
[Music]
sorry I am one of those games I'm
growing okay
yahooooo I have potion where's my health
gauge
how do I know if I'm going to die step
it's always started what found something
[Music]
okay
so what soldier boy steel is he one of
us now he's got balls this what was his
name again cloud cloud strife right and
he's my sponsor anymore still he's a
professional unlike the rest of us I'm
glad to have him this is a one-time talk
when it's done we're done no you're
supposed to be friends do I look at too
[Music]
looks are what people notice first guess
I'm not on the same page as people
he's jealous
[Music]
what do you did Wow
they've almost got the door
it's one beefy dude he's on that side
come on nobody do something this crazy
just for money they may not think you're
a true believer but you know what I
think that interested
[Music]
where's
[Music]
you better be worth the money murder
every last year
okay so I'm just paid mercenary fair
enough
I like his arm the cyborg
kind of
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's how I was locking on to the
right vibe right right
[Music]
who
got a boy guess you're first up
right oh god what my day I want to use
my sales site
[Music]
okay hopefully one guy oh what's this oh
cool
yes you see that
[Music]
I have a potion okay so it's just kind
of a screen that tells me the boys and I
have it down the bottom right
died
oh great help
he's never and down
[Music]
and the event yes oh yeah I have a
grenade
can I use it yes she's not like our dogs
any of these guys crazy it's not maybe
you'll get both ah sweet
wait someone else oh shut up
[Music]
you see me spamming eggs gotta go fast
you're better than this I want to see
the dog
[Music]
okay
I like that guy although the all the
restaurant is already talking to me much
I'm cold
[Music]
wah I can't just roll if I have want to
on the roll
[Music]
wait like guys don't we I'll be with you
I just want to check the environment for
boxes
[Music]
Bugsy's
[Music]
my HP isn't that good is it right
[Music]
yes but better
huh not so fast
we've got company it's okay mom oh my
god that dog is free I did not realize
it like that what do you mean I thought
I had no grenade like I Oh
[Music]
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] does happen they have
grenades then okay this is not fair
[Music]
you're welcome
yes wait did I just get hurt on my own
grenade
[Music]
[Music]
II know you limits feel like I'm
starting to get it don't judge me too
much
[Music]
Oh a mini-map
oh Jesus Christ
nice
leave more grenades
I thought mom
GCPD I want more grenades these
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
where we going
what you did
I wanna stay with my buddies oh I can't
obey all secure
[Music]
Final Fantasy is the bomb hey P steady
hey blue summons hey Ignacio hey Liam
Johnson
[Music]
soldiers may attack on command but I
hear they make good guard dogs - that
you've seen a few reactors so how do we
get to the bridge above Michael storage
ain't holdin out on me are you stamps
scared to bite the hand that fed him or
is he a loyal dog Oh
have it your way mud we can do this with
you or we can do this without you
different reactor different layout
depends when it was built never seen one
like this but I'll manage that guy has a
very bad temper don't you worry
Biggs we'll have the door open soon in
three two
damn I'm good oh no I didn't explore
wait take your fat [ __ ] no that's my
[Music]
every characters unique ability which
you can activate we're triangle with
valves mode shift oh he had the Punisher
mode but you can switch between this
balance operator mode and attack earlier
polish
it's a little
in punish mode cow Moos most slowly but
English is more powerful attack clouds
launches a counter blow every time he
guards against enemies mainly exact okay
he can't guard against ranged attacks on
magic when you evade such attacks to a
switch back to okay so I can't roll in
this mode I guess okay who needs to
dodge
[Music]
see you
oh there was this she nothing here cool
no though hi she was nothing yet okay
just sipping this is how you find
grenades I got this place covered well
what are you waiting for
I like destroying the environments it's
fun I got this place covered wonder if
you could have done this in the original
game but now I just want to crouch
because I want to like make a little box
for in this crouch and hide whatever
okay it's a good thing I know someone
who can get us the passcodes
hey do you know what else that command
will talk to us but what can you do
and we're good
careful in there don't mansplain
I remember always thinking that final
fantasy had like a lot of different
mechanics to learn as well but this is
pretty intuitive security is only going
to get tighter so be ready we can't
afford any more mistakes so sassy uh
looks like the elevators on another
floor mind pushing that button sure so
you know Tifa right it's not really my
business but are you guys close strong
silent type
Tifa die
I guess we won't find out yet probably
not on the demo
these sewer ads appear to call
themselves Avalanche sir we are
currently investigating whether they
belong to the same group that made the
attempt on your life rest assured our
inquiries will not take much longer
this pump sole purpose is to drain the
planet dry while you sleep
why are you we while you sit it's here
sucking up Locke oh it doesn't rest and
it doesn't care you do realize what
Marko is don't you Marko is the
lifeblood of our world the planet bleeds
cream like you and me bleed red the hell
you thinks gonna happen when it's all
gone huh answer me
you gonna stand there and pretend you
can't hear the plan crying out in pain
oh don't you care oh he cares mother
fathers cute damn straight I do get help
say that again I'd worry less about the
planet and more about the next five
seconds save the screaming for later
our lives on the line now
you listenin Merc one false move and
that happens well so much for having
cloud do all the fighting there are some
places a sword just can't reach just
bear with him for me would you should
have asked for money
I have an ally who hates me
especially arranged at home down
releases sustained at the man with the
gun how do i oh wait I'm overcome
ah
heavy hang you said that feels a large
balsam uncle long time to recharge this
take
wait
[Music]
now put a real show
you can switch different characters
spending on the buzzing situation
cool cool cool well I can issue commands
[Music]
what's that Phoenix down on arrives in
the stores
okay so if anyone's down
I don't
do your job not bad
I like that little hate-hate
relationship that will probably turn
into a love-hate lair maybe even my
loved one can dream right there any
thoughts it's around here
who stares wait
stairs up here - which way did we go
I mean this funds overcome breast
how we doing for help
look what we have here a laser security
system
we'll hurt more than your pride if
you're careless they'll cut you down to
size and then son thought I'm guessing
you've done this kind of thing before ya
figure out the timing of the lasers then
make a move when they set them off don't
mind spring to me how to play stealth
game hey just keep those baby blues of
yours on me
[Music]
yep yep yeah oh I can - it I - okay
that's good to know
oh but okay I've been Josh in anyway
fair enough
okay let's do this
yep
you're doing good
where is she is she that far ahead of us
oh my god no
ah full house
that's so fast okay oh they're in quick
breath
[ __ ] one more one more
Oh
five now do that really easy right
for nothing taking away about a whole
squad in a second
not if you went to forward them first
I'm gonna do this
Kelly's heavy weapons platform that
should give us an opaque
[Music]
have a give the orders we can't do
anything
oh I don't have enough of my stuff I do
though
temporary not like balance and pressured
will appear under their gauge when this
happens help them with spells and
abilities to quickly fill their stagger
gauge once it's full you can stagger
them and the gauge feels faster
depending on the abilities and magic use
as well as the phase one of it so is he
vulnerable to my choir then I'm guessing
hey it's double let's pin it down give
it all you got
[Music]
lightning let's see how it reacts the
light
you just had to get back up yeah
but to eat sweet food steam
Stargate
the defense's the people Thomas using
unique abrasive from soccerpro will
quickly be shot gauge booster booster ok
don't need to tell me twice
enjoy
water twenty-something first soldier
first class doesn't go into the toys
talking about I mean your name's not to
goddamn right I don't fall I know my
soldiers break could be the same as is a
[Applause]
hmm
for one second I thought they were gonna
explode cuz you know red balls
wait nice take it with us
no no okay so I can't give them
did you take the reactor core right at
the bone at the bottom let's get down
hey Jo soo and someone Arabic and troll
Oh
more like excited I've been dreaming
about this for years
interesting dreams
I want more grenades
you're choosing me over the reactor
that's sweet but only my turn
why she's a slight girl down the ladder
dummy okay okay
oh no no puck huh
this one
come on I'm waiting [ __ ] the air
together I need to beam in
other sub there I didn't cheat on my
loving in the way no time to celebrate
we ride down to the bar
no the
I am so slow in this mode
all done
serves you right how we doing oh one of
the bad well I'm so heal us a little bit
you're very welcome sir
let's do this let's do this
all right let's see if little stamp
really can bite the hand what exactly
are we doing go on do the honors prove
to me you're the man Tifa says you are
that you're one of us
never son out I'm just here for the
paycheck do the damn job
oh please summer says that boss fight is
coming up or at least that's what they
sense
wait what what's wrong
you see a feather and it's disappeared
some desert with this guy's head I'm
fine
what about the timing flashback system
they call Merc
2013 2013
but more time that long enough for you
shut up
I don't know everyone said 20 heads up I
think I don't think that was wrong right
already
yeah
where do they go
no [ __ ] bullshot secret yeah
whatever they Terry I tell you whenever
I get fired
yeah
[Music]
I know he did give me a hint on how to
kill it but I wasn't very listening yeah
I think I need to learn how this thing's
right
boom boom boom boom badoom l can she
find your party members with unblockable
attacks if your party's balance got
anything you wanna say oh [ __ ] funny way
to ask for help
[Music]
didn't I tell you to use magic try and
take it
didn't last
[Music]
now [ __ ]
[Music]
how about
Oh myself
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
a visual fortune in this
a barrier never seen this defense system
so doc you would yet so what's your
brilliant plan cheese
[Music]
bingo focus on that Court
[Music]
Oh hard and fast you heard the man it's
my time to shine when they get okay
to get go viola
oh my god
in the reticula
another barrier
wait he's a winter he's a mute
[Music]
that's cool I got some extra points for
like dodging like that even I just do
very well
alright wait I need to do on this field
science loads of this one
[Music]
[ __ ] oh my god
[ __ ]
alright see ya
[Music]
[Music]
okay
just tell me into that nice wait
cutscene
I don't think I'm very good but I can't
bow
don't get hit take cover behind the
Supreme Oh what debris debris debris OK
Go Go Go Go hurry up you bake along
now go
[Music]
wait I can help 1200 the debris is gone
oh [ __ ] off out of memorize
gotta memorize it or something it is
minus one
find cover and hunker down
[Music]
now
[Music]
fire on fire on fire on fire on fire
scheisse taking damage and stubborn um
erases limits taking damage and
staggering enemies kills your limit
gauge when the cages for you can use a
Limit Breaks
which are extremely powerful attacks you
are made to suspend okay so taking
damage is sometimes I guess
[Music]
[Music]
with these
[Music]
hey Kevin hey did
strike that at Davenport fires again
[Music]
but I was too late I was too late
[Music]
military-grade armory
get shot be my guest
look out your stupid slowmode okay
no one kick butt right now before it
fires again no none of that money gets
in
[Music]
it's on you
while since I had to go all out
[Music]
here comes the lead
if you know they do it
strike now before it fires again
that means
[Music]
they just do I just kill Kathy this is
pressing so many buttons
[Music]
I'm done our health is like regenerating
outs that everyone in segments
oh I am way ahead of humor
[Music]
no time to waste let's take it out quick
[Music]
you pick up
without go
[Music]
there goes our chance to do some real
damage
no Punisher gonna get when you punish
them up [ __ ] just took you to picture a
level up did we kill it my man
despondent
No
[Music]
the ball
well at least I gave myself 30 minutes
we have more time together
you hear that damn thing Suja how it's
done
come on we've gotta move 30 minutes we
got this
I'm Killa how they chose the the longer
one oh this means like an explorer it's
okay I'm sure about the name
[Music]
concentrate
yeah yeah kill I think I can kill
everything while getting out shorty you
think what do you guys think I think I
can do
you know what I'm glad that I didn't
choose easy thanks for believing in me
people even though I swag just look down
on someone steadily so I was gonna die
[Music]
my hero thing you're right now I'm on
you Justin huh speaking Keres
about her anomaly this route should lead
us straight to berry
oh she's gone Wow Wow she is
I cannot be that speedy
[Music]
wait something's down there
I'm skating
I mean I don't think I need half an hour
because this is real time as a mentee
eight minutes with
[Music]
okay the cameras fixed so I can see him
something gonna happen he's showing word
again
cigarettes I've got to growth I want to
play a sound way up an ex-soldier boy
here
cool it five seconds is all we need
let's go the other way
yeah
[Music]
you need success because you need to
carry the boxes young man that's true I
need to play with all the boxes right I
do need this time Oh scheisse okay okay
I didn't matter you and this one being
here
[Music]
[Music]
a second step Dagon
[Music]
II
the [ __ ] lasers other Olaf
spying boxes here
but where are you what you face
sure you could yeah well you need any
did cuz I hated bran Oh
Oh
[Music]
well
[Music]
let's go
yes
give me three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh right shitless it's on you Oh watch
it learn
nothing to it oh now they can be the bun
[Music]
that's not correct think that some timer
was faulty
[Music]
sir
[Music]
I like it
onam video game come on come on
oh wait
that's one extremely impatient dude
[Music]
this is cool the whole screen is shaking
very cool okay
oh if I couldn't believe me you'd be the
first to know
I'll take that as a yes the other guy
left him here
the one that was nice to us beginning
okay yes it was buddy cool all right
come on
like taking all the green stuff on the
earth that the big dude was getting all
passionate about hence why we were
destroying it but then yeah what happens
to all of the energy source
we're doing it for the good of the
planet oh it's just a girl that was
mentioned and she asked us about our
relationship with her
guessing maybe Oh he's for you but the
flower is chest as a charity cake how
how long does this flower survive I
don't think we were wearing it when we
played just now I hope we actually get
to play with the flower on her chest and
that wasn't just for the cinematic that
was cute
ah back to the nice wholesome music yeah
now it's very nice I can see why people
are excited about it I'm still very
confused because well I've never played
Final Fantasy before but it seems like
the narrative is about taking back power
from the man I guess come like Anarchy I
quite like that and fighting for freedom
and nature and all that kind of stuff
seems quite cute
even though obviously that was a really
short demo and very kind of heavily
combat focused you can see that they
have focused or they do focus on
character arcs and character
relationships and developments as well
which is quite sweet so yeah I don't
know not sure if I would buy this game
but it's good only because there's other
games that I definitely need to buy
first but I'd be up for it perhaps in
the future
I admire as well how they have kept it
true to the originals with the
turn-based combat but they have
incorporated it so that people like me
who don't often play embrace number two
stand it very easy and intuitive
I love combat styles like all the Arkham
games where you let you just kind of
span buttons but managed to do really
cool combos and as you get to know it's
kind of about for more about timing so
if you can dodge well then it feels the
flow feels really nice especially when
you have multiple and it needs to kind
of quickly dodge and fight and kick and
do your combo attacks and all this stuff
and having the Adige turn-based put in
there as well where you can kind of stop
and think about what spells you want to
use
have that time to manage multiple
different characters it's a nice little
addition to that style of of combi I
guess I rambling but I liked it overall
[Music]
still kind of confused on the narrative
because I thought I thought at the
beginning that we were chasing them
because they were like the bad guys
whatever but for some reason they just
ran away from us and let me kill people
oh wait no that was right because I was
hired as the mercenary so that was kind
of my job yes okay that makes sense now
that's why they ran away and let me let
me take the fight because I was getting
paid for that
so make sense what did you guys think I
know most of you in the comments were
probably your probably final fantasy
fans I'm guessing so I wonder how that
was watching someone who has never
played final fantasy before you're
probably just yelling at me like no of
course and all the bad guys oh my god
how could you not know but I hope it was
entertaining
either way um flower physics as well
flower physics maths how's all this
changes everything
if you know me and you follow me on
Instagram you know I'm quite the nature
lover I love anything to do with nature
you should give the original try now
maybe maybe so I will just let you know
for any newcomers here I try and stream
at least once a week I took a little bit
of a couple weeks hiatus because I did
go to France Oh
for reasons that I cannot let you know
yet oh annoying but I will be back
streaming again next week and it will be
a longer stream this time I'm gonna try
and finish life is strange before
resident evil theory comes out I'm so
frickin excited how long have we got
until Wesleyville tree it's next month
isn't it it's like the beginning of next
month I think it's a third or something
and the demo for that will be coming out
soon as well so as soon as the demo from
resident evils comes out
I will be playing that game I'm so
frickin excited
kannaway
a job in France no it wasn't no too hot
in France but it was a nice time I had
in France it was good so yes so many
good games are coming I actually can't
wait I'm saving up so much money because
I need to buy Animal Crossing and I'm
gonna get the version with the pins from
uh the Nintendo store and Resident Evil
obviously Last of Us that to some points
yes this is a good year for games a very
good year for games
not anymore that I have forgotten
prepare your wallets prepare your
wallets better Eva 3 remake is coming
already
yeah I know I believe it it's so quick
isn't it I reckon they were probably
making it alongside number 2 or at least
while they were maybe fixing up the bugs
and suffer Resident Evil 2 because yeah
it's come so fast
the announce ghosts of Tsushima to
Tsushima I can't say it release date
today - did they that's cool
I need to look check out that yes like a
new way smooth as usual just said that
the Resident Evil meet remake is out on
April 3rd so I'll be playing that game
as soon as it's out canna Wayne oh yes
Thank You P steady so if you want to be
up to date on when these live streams
are and also what I'm what other
projects I'm working on because I do
work on quite a few projects alongside
streaming for you guys I like to wow I
say I like to develop games that's like
my day job but also I have a game
perfection that I need to update very
very soon well as soon as I can whatever
we'll talk about that later
I'm also writing a horror story or I've
written one but
turning it into a video and there's some
music stuff as well that I do but if you
want to follow me on all my little
escapades you can follow me on discord
or well become part of the discord
server so let me just get the invitation
link up
[Music]
pop so many servants
[Music]
piqué
discord or if you following me on
Twitter I'm usually pretty active on
there as well giving you the updates on
what I'm doing and when I'm gonna be
live so thank you very much for watching
I hope this wasn't too annoying to watch
such a newbie press and play Final
Fantasy who has no idea who any of the
characters are or where the story is but
hey ho I enjoyed it and I enjoyed those
box physics much fun so I'll say goodbye
to who I can see in the chat and I am
sure I will see you again racing so
goodbye Nikki so glad you could come
this time to the stream hope you can
come to the next stream or future
streams goodbye peace teddy
goodbye smooth as usual goodbye the real
Baja Co Baraka goodbye
zou Milanovic goodbye
Piero's apana goodbye
troll Oh Lucifer goodbye yeah here
goodbye Michael Costanza goodbye hero of
time goodbye today already seen some
line of it goodbye goodbye goodbye
please summarize 101 goodbye I Jamie
give I growl oh oh I already said that
Lucifer and thank you for this up
goodbye Ross well goodbye grim
matchstick and also hello and goodbye to
anyone who is watching but it's not in
the chat or to anyone that I might have
missed out it's been good coming back
next time hopefully over my PC so be a
much better setup and my head won't be
in the way of things
cool oh sweet apparently I the real
becaus name right I'm not usually very
good at doing this that's a good thing
that's a good thing
all right have a lovely day or evening I
will see you next week
yeah cool bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye trying everyone see stop
the broadcast some place it oh yeah here
you go
obviously okay right yeah